unfortunately sometimes requests fail
there are many reasons this could happen
and it's important that your app take
into account errors so that it doesn't
completely break if an ajax request
doesn't work jquery gives us the dot
error method which we can change to the
ajax request we make earlier this dot
error method goes into effect if the
ajax request fails for whatever reason
for this quiz setup error handling for
the new york times request your app
should display New York Times articles
cannot be loaded if the request fails to
test air handling there are a few
different ways you can do it for one you
could simply load the website and then
disconnect your internet that will
definitely fail or you could always
purposely mess up the URL in which case
it's definitely going to fail because
the New York hazards of times.com is
definitely not the website we're looking
for if all goes well or rather should I
say if all goes wrong you should see
this message appear on the page check
the link in the instructor notes for
more on the error method try chaining
the jQuery error method to the end of
your Ajax request and that should take
care of any failing requests check HERE
when you're done